I definitely don't think about things in recursion, not even initially. And my default way of thinking about things is like the collection-oriented. My collection happens to be an array. Yeah, yeah. But, you know, if you're in Haskell, any other functional language, it's composing operations on these collections. I assume you did that with some kind of hash set or something like that. Yeah, I just threw them in an audit set.
我绝对不会用递归来思考问题，甚至最初也不会。我思考问题的默认方式是面向集合的。我的集合恰好是一个数组。是的，没错。但是，你知道，如果你在 Haskell 或其他任何函数式语言中，它就是对这些集合进行操作组合。我假设你是用某种哈希集合之类的东西做的。是的，我只是把它们扔进了一个有序集合里。
So I was doing these in BQN. You were doing these in C++, I said. Originally in C++, although another aspect of advent of code is that, At some point, dynamic programming rears its head, which is to say memoization. And indeed, this year was no different to previous years, like some time around, I think, of day five or six. In particular, there are graph problems, which immediately become fairly trivial if you can just say, memorize the function.
所以我是在 BQN 中做这些的。你说你是在 C++ 中做的。最初是在 C++ 中，尽管 Advent of Code 的另一个方面是，在某个时候，动态规划会显露出来，也就是记忆化。确实，今年和往年没什么不同，比如在大约第五或第六天的时候。特别是，有一些图论问题，如果你能直接记忆化函数，它们就会变得相当简单。
Is an auto I equals Stoodmax element, begin, end? And why is this elegant? Because you are storing the iterator, aka essentially the index, and the value at the same time in this eye. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 267 recorded on December 22, 2025. My name is Connor. Today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about Advent of Code 2025 in C++ and BQN, days two and three. It is December. Today, as we record, it's the December 22nd.
是一个 auto i 等于 std::max_element, begin, end？为什么这很优雅？因为你同时在 i 中存储了迭代器（也就是本质上的索引）和值。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 267 期，录制于 2025 年 12 月 22 日。我是 Connor。今天，我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起聊聊 2025 年 Advent of Code 的 C++ 和 BQN 实现，主要是第二天和第三天。现在是 12 月。我们录制今天的节目时，是 12 月 22 日。
Yes, Avent of Code. Have you been doing it? I have, yes. And this year, have you looked at it this year? So this year, it's a little different. Okay. You know, it's a lot of work for Eric every year. Eric spends, you know, he starts, what is it, he starts in spring or something. You know, like it's a significant amount of work for. Eric and his team of testers and you know that kind of those folks who work on it anyway he's
是的，Advent of Code。你一直在做吗？是的，我一直在做。今年你看了吗？今年有点不同。好吧。你知道，这对 Eric 来说每年都是很大的工作量。Eric 花了，你知道，他从春天就开始了，或者类似的时间。你知道，这对 Eric 和他的测试团队，以及那些参与工作的人来说，是一项巨大的工作量，总之他
been doing it what 10 years now 2015 was the first one so 2025 now is the 11th one I think that's right and fair play it's just too much work for him to fit into his schedule which means that this year it is only 12 days it's still there but it's cut down to 12 really that that explains a lot. So it's over. It's, you know, here we are 22nd of December, and yes, advent of code is already over. I did not know that. So, I mean, I was not in Toronto at the beginning of December.
已经做了，有 10 年了吧？2015 年是第一届，所以 2025 年现在是第 11 届，我想应该是这样。说实话，这对他来说工作量太大了，无法塞进他的日程安排中，这意味着今年只有 12 天。它还在，但缩减到了 12 天。真的，这解释了很多。所以它结束了。你知道，现在是 12 月 22 日，是的，Advent of Code 已经结束了。我不知道这一点。所以，我的意思是，12 月初我不在多伦多。
I was in Australia. And there, I think it drops at 3 p.m. or 4 p.m., depending on which city in Australia you're in. Okay. I did the first two days. And then the third day, I was, how do I word this, upset by the difficulty of part B. I algorithmically thought about it and knew how to solve it. And I just thought to myself, I did not want to implement this. And so I stopped.
我在澳大利亚。在那里，我想它是在下午 3 点或 4 点发布的，取决于你在澳大利亚的哪个城市。好吧。我做了前两天。然后第三天，我，该怎么说呢，被 B 部分的难度搞得心烦意乱。我在算法上思考过它，也知道怎么解决。但我只是对自己说，我不想实现它。所以我停下来了。
So I got two and a half days into it. And for the listener, if you've been following along, it was the question where you're given a sequence of digits and you need to find, like, the largest part a is find the largest two digit number which is pretty trivial um and there's some criteria that like you know it's in from left to right or something uh it's it's not just extract the two greatest digits i don't think there's there's some extra criteria maybe and then part b is do the same thing but for nine digits which is for day three oh i was shocked interesting uh because it's not algorithmically that difficult yeah i I found day three easier than day two, actually.
所以我做了两天半。对于听众来说，如果你一直在关注，就是那个给你一串数字，你需要找到，比如，A 部分是找到最大的两位数，这相当简单，嗯，还有一些标准，比如它是从左到右之类的，呃，我不认为这只是提取两个最大的数字，我想还有一些额外的标准，然后 B 部分是做同样的事情，但针对九位数，那是第三天的题目。哦，我感到很震惊，有趣，呃，因为在算法上它并不那么难。是的，我实际上觉得第三天比第二天更容易。
All right, well, here we go. We're into it, folks. And I don't even remember what, I don't think I was very happy about day one or day two either. I think day two, I think was easier than day one. I mean, let's just pull it up. Or if you remember, you can, what should we talk about, though? Should we talk about day three first, day one first, day two first?
好吧，好吧，我们开始吧，伙计们。我甚至不记得，我不认为我对第一天或第二天感到非常满意。我想第二天比第一天更容易。我的意思是，让我们把它调出来。或者如果你记得，你可以，我们应该聊些什么呢？我们应该先聊第三天，第一天，还是第二天？
I don't know. I'm not sure I can claim to remember any one day in particular, but, um 2025 all right i got they i got five stars folks all right yeah i've more or less stalled out at 21 stars i haven't done which is so there are 24 total but without vent code you always get the last one for free i think so i so i'm just missing part two of day nine and 10 which are the really difficult part two's and and i guess to follow up on my previous statement when i said that makes a lot of sense my reasoning was that because there's only 12 days, they ratchet up
我不知道。我不确定我能声称记得哪一天特别深刻，但是，嗯，2025 年，好吧，我拿到了五颗星，伙计们。好吧，是的，我在 21 颗星左右基本上停滞不前了，我还没做，总共有 24 颗，但没有 Advent of Code，你总是能免费得到最后一颗，我想。所以我只是错过了第九天和第十天的第二部分，那是真正困难的第二部分。我想接着我之前的陈述，当我说明这很有道理时，我的理由是，因为只有 12 天，它们会更快地提高难度。话虽如此，你说你觉得第三天……是的，我不认为，你知道，我不认为难度提升得特别快。今年并没有给我留下那种印象，所以从某种意义上说，每年都有那么一两天在难度上脱颖而出。
the difficulty more quickly. That being said, you said you found day three. Yeah, and I don't think that's, you know, I don't think the difficulty ratches up particularly. This year doesn't strike me as having, so in some sense, every year has one or two days that stand out in difficulty.
所以今年也不例外，但我没有注意到今年难度有特别陡峭的攀升。好吧。但我可以说，你知道，在某个时候，较难的题目往往会难得多，以至于人们经常使用库
So this year is no exception there, but I didn't notice a particular steeper ramp of difficulty this year. Okay. But I can say you know, at some point, the harder ones tend to be significantly harder to the point where oftentimes folks use a library
来解决它，比如线性代数库或其他什么库。当我遇到这样的问题时，我往往会，这往往会让我有点退缩。哦，我明白了。有时我可以在没有库的情况下完成它们，有时这就是我停滞不前的地方。在某个时候，我的大脑只是说，
to solve it, like a linear algebra library or whatever it might be, or a graph library. When I come up against questions like that, I tend to, that tends to put me off a bit. Oh, I see. And sometimes I can do them without a library, and sometimes that's where I just stall out. At some point, my brain just says,
好吧，你知道，如果有库，那么解决方案就存在了，所以这个问题就不再有趣了，这是一种思维方式，对吧？好吧，那么我们还应该，如果你心里有一个想聊的问题，我们可以聊那个，但呃，如果没有，我们可以聊第三天、第二天。好吧，让我们聊聊你解决过的一个，我想是的，我对任何一个都持开放态度。我很好奇，呃，我很想听听你的第三天解决方案，如果你觉得它更容易的话。但问题是，我们应该先做第二天，然后再谈第三天，还是先做第三天，然后再回到第二天？让我们谈谈第二天。所以第二天，如果我没记错的话，你得到的是这些连字符分隔的数字，对吧，代表范围
well you know if there's a library then the solution exists so the problem isn't interesting anymore it's kind of that train of thought right all right so what should we what should we also too if you had a question in mind that you wanted to to chat about we can chat about that one but uh if not we can chat about day three day two well let's chat about one that you've tackled i think so i'm open to any of them i'm curious uh i'm curious about hearing your day three solution if you think it was easier but the question is should we do day two first and then talk about day three or do day three and then go back to day two let's talk about day two so day two if i refresh my memory you're given these hyphen separated numbers right representing ranges
代表范围，是的，然后它要求你找到无效的 ID，我相信无效性在于如果它们有重复的序列，对吧？所以对于第一部分，具体来说，一个无效的 ID 有两次，嗯，一次重复，有数字序列的重复。所以任何两位数，但它只是双重重复，不是三次重复，四次重复，对吧？这对于第一部分很重要，意思是如果你把你的数字切成两半，你应该有相同的两半，或者说字符串或数字的两个分区。所以立刻，它只能是偶数位数的数字。是的。而且我觉得它不是说只有偶数吗？
that represent ranges yeah and then it asks you to find invalid IDs that i believe have the invalidness is that if they have repeated sequences correct so for part one specifically an invalid ID has a twice well one time repeated has as has a repetition of a sequence of digits so any two digit number but it is only a double repetition it's not three repetitions four repetitions right that's important for part one meaning that if you if you slice your digit or not digit. If you slice your number in half, you should have the same two halves or partitions of that string or number. So immediately, it's only numbers with an even number of digits. Yeah. And I think doesn't it actually say that is there only even numbers or
也许不是？好吧，你得到了，你得到了范围。任务是让你算出所有无效 ID 的总和。有效的 ID 是任何范围内的任何数字，具有两半相同的属性。对。我的意思是，我对此没做任何花哨的事情。我只是对这两部分都进行了暴力破解。第一部分，暴力破解根本不需要时间。第二部分，所以第二部分是无效的，不仅如果你把它切成两半，而且如果你把它切成任何等长的分区。所以如果你有一个九位数的数字，你把它切成三个长度为三的部分，如果它们都有相同的相等值，那也是无效的，你可以用许多库中存在的算法来暴力破解它，它存在吗？它不存在，我想它确实
maybe not? Well, you're given, you're given ranges. The task is for you to figure out the sum of all of the invalid IDs. And valid ID is any number in any range which has the property of being in two halves identical. Right. I mean, I did nothing fancy for this. I just brute force this for both parts. The first part, brute forcing it takes no time at all. The second part, so the second part is invalid, not just if you slice it in half, but if you slice it into any equally lengthed partitions. So if you have a nine digit number and you slice it into three parts of length three if those all have the same equal value that is also invalid and you can brute force that with an algorithm that exists in many libraries and it does it exist it doesn't i guess it does
存在于呃 C++23 中的 chunk 形式，所以如果你，好吧，如果你以字符串的形式按所有可能的长度对你的数字进行分块，你知道，二到多少，我想我可能只是做了长度的一半？我甚至不知道。但无论如何，你从二做到任何可能的长度，然后你只需检查其中任何一个，你知道，你的字符串的分区是否无效。这只需要几秒钟。
exist in uh c plus plus 23 in the form of chunk um so if you okay if you chunk your number in the form of a string by all potential lengths you know two to whatever i'm i think i might have just done half of the length? I don't even know. But anyways, you do it from two to whatever length could possibly be, and then you just check if any one of those, you know, partitionings of your string is invalid. It takes a couple seconds.
我是在 BQN 中做这个的，但 BQN 有一个用于分块窗口的基元。总之，我对此没做任何优雅的事情。我不确定你是否有更优雅的解决方案。现在我得找到我的解决方案。实际上，我说过 BQN 有一个 chunk 函数，但实际上它有一个 Windows 基元，chunk 可以建立在它之上。
I did this in BQN, but BQN as a primitive for kind of chunking up your window. Anyway, so I did nothing elegant for this. I'm not sure if you had a more elegant solution. Now I have to find my solution. Actually, I said that BQN has a chunk function, but actually it has a Windows primitive. that chunk can be built on top of.
总之，我可以链接到这些解决方案。它们并不漂亮，因为我只是在几分钟内搞定了它。它奏效了。有趣的是，看起来我没有那样做。我没有检查范围内的每个数字，而是尝试生成所有无效数字，然后看看它们是否在范围内。所以我采取了相反的方法。
Anyways, I can link to the solutions. They're not pretty because I just kind of hacked this in a few minutes. It worked. I did, interestingly, it looks like I didn't do that. Rather than checking every number in the range, what I did was try to generate all the invalid numbers and then see if they were within the ranges. So I took a approach from the other way.
我没有枚举数字并检查它们是否有效，我生成了无效数字并检查它们是否在范围内。你生成了所有无效数字。我的意思是，限制是什么？在范围内。好吧，我生成了在给定范围内的特定无效数字。我明白了。但在这样做时，我必须小心一点，因为当然，你可能会意外地重复一个数字，因为数字 1-1-1-1 以两种不同的方式无效，对吧？它无效是因为它是 1 的四重重复，但它也是 11 的二二重复，对吧？对，所以如果它们不是双重计数数字，你必须确保考虑到这一点。我假设你是用某种哈希集合之类的东西做的。是的，我只是把它们扔进了一个有序集合里，我，是的，我们还没谈过，所以我是在 BQN 中做这些的，你是在 C++ 中做的。我假设最初是在 C++ 中，尽管 Advent of Code 的另一个方面是，在某个时候，动态规划会显露出来，也就是记忆化。确实，今年和往年没什么不同，比如在大约第五或第六天的时候，特别是，有一些图论问题，
I didn't enumerate the numbers and check to see if they were. valid, I generated invalid numbers and checked if they were in the ranges. You generated all invalid numbers. I mean, what's the limit? Within the range. Well, I generated invalid numbers specifically within the ranges given. I see. But in doing that, I had to be a little careful because, of course, you can accidentally duplicate a number because the number 1-1-1-1 is invalid in two different ways, right it's in value because it's a full way repetition of ones but it's also a two two repetition of 11 right right and so you have to be sure to account for that kind of thing if they're not double
如果能直接记忆化函数，它们就会变得相当简单。所以在那一点上，如果你在 C++ 中，你还有更多工作要做。但如果你在 Python 中，这就很简单了。你只需添加 cache 装饰器，是的，完全正确。或者 cache，是的，它就叫这个。
count numbers i assume you did that with some kind of hash set or something like that yeah i just threw them in an ordered set and i yeah we haven't talked about so i was doing these in bqn you were doing these in c++ i assume originally in c++ although another aspect of aventa code is that at some point dynamic programming rears its head, which is to say, memoization. And indeed, this year was no different to previous years, like sometime around, I think, of day five or six, in particular, there are graph problems,
我想我们想要。是的，来自 functools，我想，是的。是的。所以我切换到 Python 来完成 Advent of Code 的后半部分。好吧。有趣。所以你生成了无效数字，我想起初这看起来工作量会很大。但其实还不错。
which immediately become fairly trivial if you can just say, memorize the function. And so at that point, if you're in C++, plus, you've got more work to do. But if you're in Python, it's trivial. You can just add the cache. Decorator, yeah, exactly. Or cache, yeah, that's what it's called.
好吧，这应该比枚举所有数字的工作量要小，我是这么想的。而且我预计仅仅通过枚举所有数字来进行暴力破解工作量会太大。也许我对此错了。我当然是对的，你知道，随着 Advent of Code 的进行，这当然是需要记住的事情，比如暴力破解解决方案在 Advent of Code 的后期阶段对于第二部分是不够的。是的，我的意思是，我也认为潜在地，我知道第一部分没问题，因为它只是线性的，对吧？
I think we want. Yeah, from Funk Tools, I think, yeah. Yeah. So I switched over to Python for the second half of Advent of Code. Okay. Interesting. So you generated the invalid numbers, which I guess it kind of at first, it seems like it would be a lot of work. But it's not too bad.
所以没问题。B 部分，我不太确定，但我认为，啊，做暴力破解足够简单了，你知道，只需把我的数字分块，检查它是否无效。问题是你从，你知道，从长度为二的块一直做到你的整数可能达到的任何长度。对。这意味着你有一个非线性解决方案。复杂度是多少，我其实不知道。而且实际上比复杂度更重要的是，你正在对你的字符串或数字形式的字符串进行这种分区，而且这，呃，你会分配很多内存，所以就像我说的，我不太确定，但它在，我不知道，五到七秒左右就运行完了，所以我当时想，哦，好吧，它对我来说有效，不是一个漂亮的解决方案，但只要
Well, it should be less work than enumerating all of the numbers, was my thought. And I was expecting that it would be too much work to just do brute force by enumerating all the numbers. Maybe I was wrong about that. I was certainly right, you know, as advert the code goes on, that is certainly something to bear in mind, like brute force solutions don't cut it for part two in the later stages of advent the code. Yeah, I mean, I also thought that potentially, I knew for part one it would be fine because it's only linear, right?
我不必等五分钟让它运行，是的，为 BQN 实现的速度点赞。总之，对于这一点，虽然它不是特别漂亮，但我认为它相当直接，但即使如此，我还是觉得，我不知道，我不太喜欢第二题。我当时已经在想，是的，你知道，像往年一样，我记得第一题或第二题是，我不知道，把那些换行符分隔的数字加起来，你会有像一堆整数，对吧？你必须把它们解析成子列表，然后你只需把它们加起来，我就想，你知道，这就是我开始 24 天旅程的一个很好的方式，呃，到了第二天，我已经，就像，在伸手去拿库函数了。
so it's fine. Part B, I was not convinced, but I thought, ah, it's easy enough to do a brute force, you know, just chunk my numbers up, check if it's invalid. The problem is that you're doing it from like, you know, a chunk length of two to whatever length your integer could be. Right. And that means that you have a nonlinear solution. What the complexity is, I don't actually know. And actually more than the complexity is the fact that you're doing this like partitioning of your string or like number in form of a string and like that is uh you're going to be allocating a bunch and so like i said i wasn't convinced but it ran in like i don't know five or seven seconds or something so i was like oh well it works for me not a pretty solution but like
在往年，实际上，在早期，我有时尝试在没有编程的情况下解决它们。哦，是的，在 Excel 或其他什么软件里。好吧，甚至 Excel 也可以被视为一种编程形式。我的意思是，我猜我确实是在用编程解决它们。但是，例如，早期的一道题，甚至可能是 2015 年第一年的第一天，非常早期的题目之一是找到匹配的右括号，对吧？你得到一个带有任意杂乱的文本文件，嗯，不是杂乱，它们是匹配的，但有不同括号对的任意嵌套，巨大，基本上是一个巨大的 S 表达式。对。对。所以，就像什么字符，给出 N，其中结束字符是第一个字符的闭括号。所以我只是把它加载进去。好吧，是的，我在 Emacs 中加载它。我输入 forward S expression，跟随点。
as long as i'm not waiting five minutes for this thing to run yeah shout out to the speed of bQN's implementation anyway so for this even though it wasn't super pretty i thought it was pretty straightforward but but even even i thought this was i don't know i i wasn't in love with question two i was already being like yeah you know like in years past like i remember question one or two was like i don't know sum up the numbers that are like a new line separated you'd have like a chunk of integers right you'd have to parse those into sub lists and then you just add them up and i was like you know that's what i have a nice little way to start off my 24 day journey and uh by day two i'm I'm already, like, reaching for library functions.
那就是答案。是的。是的，是的。然后我想你只需删除其余部分，或者选择并计算字符数，或者类似的东西。但是的，所以无论如何，这个问题绝对比那个难。但无论如何，所以第三天。对，第三天。我就是在那里迷失的，你得到一个，这看起来像什么，连续 15 或 20 个数字？
In previous years, actually, in the early days, I tried to solve them without programming sometimes. Oh, yeah, in Excel or whatever. Well, even Excel could be viewed as a form of programming. I mean, I guess I am solving them with programming. But, for example, one of the early, maybe even day one of year one, 2015, very early ones was find the matching close paren, right? You're given a text file with an arbitrary. jumble, well, not jumble, they are matched, but an umptory nesting of different
你被要求找到最大的可能电压，也就是数字。标准是什么？你在这里选择两个数字，你必须保持它们的稳定性，也就是顺序。所以如果有一个 9 和一个 8，但 8 在前面，你不允许组成数字 98。你必须组成数字 89。
per N pairs, huge, basically one huge S expression. Right. Right. So, so it's like what character, give, give N, where the end character is the closing perenn for the first character. So I just load it up. Well, yeah, I load it up in Emacs. I type forward S expression, followed by point.
所以这基本上是唯一的标准。但数字不必是相邻的。对，是的。所以你是在找子集。是的，通过删除其余数字的一部分可以获得的最大两位数，如果你愿意的话。完全正确。
That's the answer. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Then I guess you just delete the rest or select and count the number of characters or whatever it is. But yeah, so anyways, this problem definitely harder than that. But anyway, so day three. Right, day three. Whereas where I lost it, you're given a, what does this look like, 15 or 20 digits in a row?
所以对我来说，这是一个外积或三角积，在数组语言中非常容易做到，你基本上只需创建每一个可能的数字，然后取最大值。我的意思是，这是一种低效的方法，但它有效。但后来是 B 部分。我做这个的方法，立刻出现在我脑海中的方法是，所以你有一个数字范围，你必须从那个范围的 n-1 中选择第一个数字，因为你必须给自己至少留一个数字，你知道，你必须找到 n-1 的最大值，后面跟着你找到上一个最大值到结尾的位置的最大值，对吧？这就是你的数字。
And you're asked to find the largest possible joltage, aka number. and what are the criteria? You're choosing two numbers here and you have to keep them stable, so in order. So if there's a nine and an eight, but the eight comes first, you're not allowed to make the number 98. You have to make the number 89.
这编码起来很简单，所以我就是这么做的。而且这也可以推广到第二部分，对吧？等等，等等，实际上，所以你说你必须在 n-1 中找到第二个数字。
So that's basically the only criteria. But the numbers don't have to be adjacent. Correct, yeah. So you're finding the subset. Yeah, the largest two-digit number that can be obtained by deleting. some portion of the rest of the numbers, if you're like. Exactly.
其中最重要的数字你可以从元素 0 到 n-1 中选择，假设有，假设它将是 n-2，因为 n-1 是最后一个元素，但这有点让人困惑。
And so for me and this one, it's just an outer product or a triangle product, which are very easy to do in array languages where you basically just create every single possible number and then just take the max. I mean, that's an inefficient way to do things, but it works. But then part B. The way I did this, the method that immediately suggests itself to me was, so you've got a range of numbers you've got to pick the first number from
所以第一个元素到第 n-1 个元素是你的选择，你将选择其中最大的数字，然后在你找到最大数字的地方，你从那里到结尾去选择你的第二个数字。是的，我现在明白了，抱歉。是的，这就是推广到下一个解决方案的方法。是的，不幸的是，你是怎么用递归实现这个的？嗯，或者一个调整 i 的 for 循环，我的意思是，是的，但我的意思是，它们是同一个算法。我不认为算法是，我不认为递归与迭代在算法上有什么
n minus one of that range because you've got to leave yourself at least one number you know you've got to find the max of the n minus one followed by the max of where you found the previous max to the end right that's your number
大的区别，对我来说，思考算法的正确方式是递归的，你如何实现它们可以是递归的，也可以不是，对吧？所以对我来说，无论哪种方式，它们都是同一个算法。但我碰巧用一个 for 循环实现了它，因为它在尾递归上是平凡的，所以你可以做一个 for 循环。所以是的，我没有那样做的原因，所以那基本上是我所想的，如果，如果你把这个可视化，你可以把那个 n-1 的东西可视化为这种滑动梯形，你可以从那里选择你的数字。但在每一行，你必须根据你找到的数字的上一个索引来调整范围。所以，我们应该提到，我们是否说过第二部分到底是什么？所以第一部分是，你有一个，是什么，12 个数字，15 个数字的字符串，假设是 15 个。
that's a trivial thing to code up so that's what I did and that and that generalizes two part two as well right wait wait actually so you said you got to find the second number in n minus one
第一部分是找到最大的两位数，可以用我们说过的稳定方式选择。第二部分是找到最大的 12 位数，可以用那种方式选择，其中每个数字都被选中。是的。是的，12。出于某种原因，在我的大脑中，我把它存为 9，但是的，12。12 就是问题所在。而且谜题，实际上，谜题输入字符串。是像，我不知道，50 或 60 位长的长字符串，测试输入只有 15 个左右，但
where the the most significant digit you can pick from elements zero through n minus one let's say there are let's say that it's going to be n minus two right because n minus one is the last element but that's confusing things of it
你得到的真实输入，你有更多的数字。是的，所以我不想实现它的原因是我想用数组语言来做，我明白了，让我把我的，我可以链接你我的解决方案在这里。是的，而且我猜当我看到这个时，会有一个索引被用来做截断，或者，你知道，限制那个范围。是的，所以如果你选择两个数字，第一个来自数字，第一个到第 n-1 个，对吧？如果你选择 12 个数字，第一个来自，你知道，数字 1 到
so the first element through the n minus one's element is your choice you're going to pick the max digit of those and then where you found the max digit you go from there to the end to pick your second digit yes okay i understand now sorry and yes that is what generalizes to the next solution yeah unfortunately that how did you implement this with recursion um or a four loop that adjusts in i mean yeah but i mean they're the same algorithm it's I don't think of algorithms as being I don't think of recursion versus iteration as a
n-11，下一个数字来自你找到第一个数字的地方到 n-10，然后下一个数字到 n-9，等等，对吧？所以这个，我的意思是，这非常优雅，链接在节目说明中，伙计们，它并不那么优雅，我的意思是，它是拼凑出来的，它碰巧是我第一个想到的，而且结果代码并不多。是的，不，但它在某种意义上是优雅的，在这个解决方案的第 27 行，for 循环内的第一行是一个 auto
as a big difference in algorithms like to me the right way to think about algorithms is recursively how you implement them can be recursively or not right so to me it's the same algorithm either way but I happen to implement it with a with a full loop because it is trivially tail recursive and so you can make a full loop so yeah The reason I didn't, like, so that was what I thought of basically is in, if you kind of visualize this, you can visualize that like N minus one thing as this kind of like sliding trapezoid of where you get to select your numbers from. But then at each row, you have to adjust the range based on the previous index of your number that you found. So, so we should have we meant, have we said what part two actually is? So part one is five, you've got the string of, what is it, 12 numbers, 15 numbers, let's say 15.
i 等于 std::max_element, begin, end，为什么这很优雅？因为你同时在 i 中存储了迭代器（也就是本质上的索引）和值，这
Part one is find the largest two-digit number, which can be selected in the stable way we've said. Part two is find the largest 12-digit number that can be selected in that way, where each digit is selected. Yes. Yeah, yeah, 12. For some reason, in my brain, I had stored it as nine, but yeah, 12. 12 is what the question is. And the puzzle, actually, the puzzle input string. are like I don't know 50 60 digit long long strings the the test input is only 15 or so but the
对于定义你寻找下一个数字的实际范围至关重要。所以从循环结束倒数两行，它说让我们重置 begin，这定义了你的下一个范围为 std::next of i。
real input you get you get many more digits yeah so the the reason I didn't want to implement it is because I wanted to do this in an array language and I see let me send you my I can link you my solution here yeah and I I am I am guessing that when I see this, there's going to be an index that is used to do the truncation or, you know, kind of limiting that range. Yeah, so if you're selecting two digits, the first one comes from digits, the first through the n minus once, right? If you're selecting 12 digits, the first one comes from, you know, digit one through
所以这非常优雅。那两行，中间的两行只是在做数学计算来算出数字。所以真的，第 27 行和第 30 行至关重要。我的意思是，这可能是
n minus 11 and the next digit comes from where you found the first digit through n minus 10 and then the next digit through n minus 9 etc right so this uh i mean this is very elegant link in the show notes folks for it's not that elegant i mean it's it's hacked up it happened to me it happened to be the first thing i thought of and it turned out to be not very much code yeah no but it is elegant in the sense that on line 27 of this solution on the first line inside the for loop is an auto
我作为数组程序员的极限。每当你需要一个值的索引时，根据问题类型，得到它并不总是那么简单，你最终会做像二次查找和删除，或者基于什么取值，或者你得到什么的长度，总之，对我来说，如何优雅地进行归约是不明显的，因为归约就是最终发生的事情，基于你归约的当前步骤，而没有像这样返回给你索引和值的算法。在这种情况下，它是一个迭代器的形式，但你可以想象其他算法返回给你一个元组，你知道，值
i equals stood max element begin and why is this elegant because you are storing the iterator a.k.a essentially the index and the value at the same time in this i which is
和索引，你如何然后说，你知道，从这个范围内删除，这样你就不会在重复中进行搜索？所以也许，也许问题的一部分是我应该选择一种不同的语言，尽管我肯定有一些听众也是 Array Cast 的听众，他们认为实际上有一种模式或惯用法只是不在我的模式工具箱中。但总之，我说的有意义吗？
like essential for defining the actual range where you're looking for the next number. So two lines from the end of the loop, it says let's reset the begin, which is defining your next range to be stood next of I.
如果这对你没有意义，那么对听众来说可能也没有任何意义。窗口，所以是什么让这个问题在数组语言中，或者在函数式语言中，或者函数式语言中的某些东西变得有趣，是因为窗口的大小在变化
So that's very elegant. Those two lines there, and the two lines in between are just doing the math to calculate the number. So really, line 27 and line 30 essential. And I mean, this is maybe the limits
对吧？所以每次迭代，窗口的末尾只是增加了一。对。但窗口的开头是从你找到上一个东西的地方开始的。所以这在增加……它依赖于上一次迭代，是的。是的。
of my proficiency as an array programmer. Whenever you need the index, of a value depending on the problem type it's not always trivial to get that and you end up doing like a secondary like find and drop or take based on or like you get the length of whatever anyway so it's unobvious to me how to elegantly do basically a reduction at the end of the day because that's what's happening to based on the current step of your reduction without having an algorithm like this that returns to you both the index and the value in this case it's in the form of an iterator but you can imagine some other algorithm that returns you a tuple of you know the value
是的。在 Haskell 中，我会想象惯用的解决方案只是使用递归，因为这就是你解决这类递归问题的方式。在数组语言中，你可以访问递归。我不想写一个递归的。我想这就是我大脑想要的，就像，我可以递归地做这个，或者我可以用像 while 循环和一些本地状态来做，但这只会伤我的心，因为我不喜欢带有本地状态的 while 循环。好吧，Conner，你需要这样想。就像我五分钟前说的，思考算法的优雅方式是从递归开始，对吧？
and the index how do you then say like you know drop drop in from this range so that you're not doing your search in the duplicate and so maybe it's maybe a part of the problem is that i should have just chosen a different language although i'm sure there are some listeners that are also listeners of array cast and they're thinking that there is actually a pattern or an idiom that is just not in my tool chest of patterns but so anyways did it make sense what I
如果你能递归地解决它，你可以机械地将其转换为高效的实现。你完全可以写一个 for 循环，但这并没有改变算法的本质，对吧？你仍然可以认为算法是递归的，因为许多，如果不是大多数，算法都是那种分治法。即使你在处理线性序列时，从某种意义上说，你每次处理剩余的线性序列时都在缩小输入。
if it doesn't make sense to you then it probably didn't make it any sense to the listener the window so what makes this problem maybe interesting in the array language or indeed in a functional language or something in the functional language is that the window is changing size
所以你完全可以认为算法是递归的，这与你选择如何实现它们是分开的，对吧？是的。是的。我的意思是，我绝对，我绝对不会用递归来思考问题，甚至最初也不会。我的意思是，显然，你知道，人们说，哦，他们被递归困住了。我不会被递归困住。我只是，我，我思考问题的默认方式是面向集合的。我的集合恰好是一个数组。是的，没错。但是，你知道，如果你在 Haskell 或其他任何函数式语言中，它就是对这些集合进行操作组合。是的，我完全同意，说实话，你知道，如果你有，对于某些操作，我们可以习惯于用那种高层次的抽象来思考，即面向整体的方法，处理集合。
right so every iteration the end of the window just gets bumped by one. Right. But the beginning of the window is from wherever you found the last thing. So that's increasing... It's dependent on the previous iteration, yeah. Yeah.
但通常当一个算法不是，不立即适合那个模型，或者你看不出怎么做时，你可以走两条路。你可以，你可以继续。如果你真的习惯于思考面向整体的编程方法，所以也许这就是你思考问题的方式，你可以继续尝试说，好吧，我怎么能把这些数据混合，直到它最终变成一种我可以归约的形式，对吧？
Yeah. And in Haskell, I would imagine that the idiomatic solution is just to use recursion because that's how you solve these kinds of recursive things. In an array language, you have access to recursion. I did not want to write a recursive. I think that's what my brain want is like, I can do this recursively or I could do it with like a while loop in some local state, but that would have just hurt my heart because I don't like wall loops with local state. Well, here's how you need to think of it, Conner. Like I said five minutes ago, like the elegant way to think of algorithms is to start with recursion, right?
我可以考虑也许是一个 scan，后面跟着，你知道，一个 transform，后面跟着一个 reduction，后面跟着一个 window，无论它是什么。你知道，你可以沿着那条路走下去，我相信你能得到答案。
And if you can solve it recursively, you can mechanically translate that to an efficient implementation. You can totally write a four loop, but it doesn't change the essence of the algorithm, right? You can still think of the algorithm as being recursive because many, if not most, algorithms are that kind of divide and conquer. Even when you're working on a linear sequence, in a sense you are shrinking the input every time you're working on the remaining linear sequence.
或者，你知道，也许这种二分法不是硬性的。或者你可以考虑我将如何，你知道，基于 for 循环的方法，如果你喜欢，你知道，处理索引的方法，不是 for 循环，因为那可能意味着迭代。但是，是的，我怎么能，我怎么能分治？我将如何处理索引，以便范围缩小，那种思考方式？是的，是的。
So you can totally think of algorithms as recursive, and that is separate from your choice of how to implement them, right? Yes. Yes. I mean, I definitely, I definitely don't think about things in recursion, not even initially and not even. I mean, obviously, you know, people say, oh, they get hung up on recursion. I don't get hung up on recursion. I just, I, my, my default way of thinking about things is like the collection oriented. My collection happens to be an array. Yeah. Yeah. But, you know, if you're in Haskell, any other functional language, it's composing operations on these. collections. Yeah. And I totally agree, to be fair, you know, like if you have, for certain operations, we can be used to thinking in those kind of high-level abstractions of the whole meal-oriented approach, working on collections.
我完全同意这一点。而且我猜当我在做 Advent of Code 或 LeetCode 问题或任何那种，你知道，为了好玩的事情时。事情。我希望我不会，我希望我能保持我默认的思考方式。即使我必须从那里移动，我仍然希望递归的，或者，你知道，while 循环或 for 循环版本，我仍然可以使用我拥有的所有基元。比如，我不必写一些拼凑出来的东西。问题是，就像，不仅我不能留在我的面向集合的编程领域或数组编程
But oftentimes when an algorithm isn't, doesn't immediately fit into that model or you don't see how to do it, there are two ways you can go. You can, and you can either go, oh, how can I, you can carry on. And if you're really used to thinking about the whole meal programming approach, so maybe this is how you're thinking of things, you can carry on trying to say, well, how can I munge this data until it eventually gets into a form where I can reduce it, right?
领域。当我转向递归或 for 循环解决方案时，我现在需要创建一个基本上叫 max with index 的函数。对。你需要枚举集合并携带它。是的。你那样做的方式是首先你会找到最大值，然后用那个最大值你会回去，就像数组语言中甚至没有像 index of first 这样的函数，你必须建立一个所有值等于最大值的掩码，然后取对应于那个最大值的第一个
I can think about maybe a scan, followed by, you know, a transform, followed by a reduction, followed by a window, whatever it might be. You know, you can carry on down that row and you can get to an answer, I'm sure.
布尔值，并把它变成一个索引，然后取那些索引中的第一个。所以就像你为了得到那个最大值的第一个索引已经跳过了三个不同的障碍，这就像有一个场景来自
Or, you know, and maybe this dichotomy is not hard and fast. Or you can think about how would I, you know, the four-loop-based approach, if you like, you know, the working on the indices, let's say, the working on the indices approach, not the full-loop, because that implies maybe iteration. But, yeah, how can I, how can I divide and conquer? How would I work on the indices so that the range shrinks, that kind of way of thing? Yeah, yeah.
《疯狂动物城》，那只小兔子假装流血。哦，是的。我会把它剪进去，可能根本没意义，但就像，这就是我大脑中正在发生的事情。我只是想，好吧，我不解决这个问题了。好吧，让我对你说这个。嗯，这听起来像，你想在
That I completely agree with. And I guess when I'm doing advent of code or leak code problems or any kind of like, you know, for fun things. things. I hope that I don't, I hope I can just stay in my default way of thinking. And even if I have to move from that, I still hope that the recursive or, you know, wild loop or for loop version, I can still use all of the primitives that I have. Like, I don't have to write some bespoke thing that's an amalgamation of stuff. And the problem is, is like, not, like, it's not only can I not stay in my collection-oriented programming land or array program
像一个枚举单子（enumerated monad）里工作，对吧？你想处理那些被它们的索引丰富的值？听起来这就像是提升到枚举单子中，我不知道它是否存在，但它听起来像是一个单子。对，是的。我的意思是，如果把任何东西捆绑在一个可选类型或其他什么东西里，就像确实，把它和一个索引捆绑在一起也是一个单子，对吧？所以也许，你知道，你刚才对我说的，携带枚举状态并弄清楚你在集合枚举中的位置是笨拙和烦人的。也许抽象它的方法是把自己提升到枚举单子中。顺便说一句，我完全是编出来的，但这听起来就像应该是可用的那种东西。是的，我的意思是，那是一个，这是一个奇妙的，就像，算法思想。是的。我最初的想法是，如果你把它和原始索引序列捆绑在一起，每次后续迭代，你现在都会有一个非零索引，来自你新的序列。所以就像起初你从 0 到多少。但第二次，你在索引 6。但实际上你的列表开头是在索引 3。所以我现在需要倒推当前的索引是什么。但你不是无论如何都会手动做类似的事情吗？就像你有的，如果那是你答案的一部分，你必须携带那个状态。
land. When I go to the recursive or four-loop solution, I now need to create basically a function called like max with index. Right. You need to enumerate the collection and carry that along. Yeah. The way that you would do that is first you'd find the maximum and then with that maximum you would go back and like there's not even like a index of first function in array languages, you would have to build a mask of all of the values equal to the maximum and then take the first
好吧，所以我的意思是，如果，如果你不做那种枚举，你，如果你只是做某种像，如果你构建一个返回给你第一个带索引的最大值的元组的基元，你就可以在每次迭代时应用它，而不需要做。像，是的，你每次肯定都在做同样的工作，但你避免了现在我需要从当前索引中减去我所有索引的总和来得到正确的偏移量，但这确实是值得深思的。但另一件事是，即使你有这个像枚举单子那样的东西，在数组语言中也不是那么简单，因为你可以做像 zip with index 模式，但我猜你是，我想你是，我可能确实有效。你可以在那个双元素数组上做 max。枚举单子非常类似于状态单子，甚至环境单子，对吧？因为它不是真正
Boolean value that corresponds to that maximum and turn it into an index and then take the first of those indices. So it's like you're already jumping through three different hoops just to get the first index of that max value and it's just like there's a scene from
可写的。你从来没有读取它。所以也许它只是那个的一个小变体。是的。我的意思是，也许实际上有一种更好的方法来做这个，就像我现在用 Haskell 大脑思考，就像与其得到 max，你只是去，有一堆，是的，自从我做任何，好吧，我做过任何真正的 Haskell 编程吗？可能没有。但自从我使用这些库以来已经有一段时间了。曾经有一个 data.split.list 或 list.split，它有一堆像 chunk before, chunk after。如果有一些像 split at max 或 split at value，你仍然需要那个值。所以我的意思是，如果你计算了 max 然后你做了一个 split，我不知道。我不知道。
Zootopia where the little rabbit pretends to bleed. Oh yeah. I'll cut that in of it probably won't make any sense, but like, that's what's happening in my brain. And I'm just like, all right, I'm not solving this problem. Well, let me say this to you. Um, this sounds like, you want to work inside
我相信有类似的东西。而且 Advent of Code 的伟大之处在于，任何通往解决方案的路线都可以，只要你学到了东西，对吧？所以查看别人的解决方案并学习一种新技术并不是作弊，你完全可以那样做。是的，是的，好吧，这里有一个给听众的挑战，如果你是一个函数式或数组语言的 Advent of Code 听众，并且你有这种，这就是为什么我说，Ben 他当时说，好吧，它优雅吗？我把这个拼凑在一起，但这就是那件事，它是非常优雅的。它在第 27 行，你免费得到了 max element。你以一种优雅的方式得到了索引和值。
like a putated monad, the enumerated monad, right? You're wanting to work on values which are enriched with their index? Sounds to me like this is lifting into the enumerated monad, which I don't know that it exists, but it sounds like a monad. Right, yeah. I mean, if bundling anything in an optional or whatever, like sure enough, bundling it with an index is a monad as well, right? So maybe, you know, what you're,
就像一个枚举单子，枚举单子，对吧？你想处理那些带有索引值的数值？听起来像是要提升到枚举单子中，我不知道它是否存在，但听起来像是个单子。对，没错。我的意思是，如果把任何东西打包进可选类型之类的，那么把它和索引打包在一起肯定也是个单子，对吧？所以也许，你知道，你所说的，
What you just said to me is it's kind of clunky and annoying to have to carry around the enumerated state and figure out where you are in the enumeration of the collection. Maybe the way to abstract that is to put the lift yourself into the enumerated monad. And I'm totally making that up, by the way, but it just sounds like the kind of thing that should be available. Yeah, I mean, that is a, it's a fantastic, like, algorithmic idea. Yeah. My initial thought right away is that if you're bundling it with the original index sequence, each subsequent iteration, you're going to now have a non-zero-indexed index from like your new sequence. So like at first you go from zero to whatever. But then the second time, you're at index six. But actually the beginning of your list was at index three. So now I need to back out what the current index is. But wouldn't you be doing something like that manually anyway? Like you're having, if that's part of your answer, you're having to carry along that state.
你刚才对我说的意思是，必须随身携带枚举状态并弄清楚你在集合枚举中的位置，这有点笨拙且烦人。也许抽象这种操作的方法是把自己提升到枚举单子中。顺便说一句，我完全是瞎编的，但这听起来确实应该是可以实现的东西。是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常棒的算法构思。是的。我立刻想到的第一点是，如果你把它和原始索引序列打包在一起，那么在随后的每次迭代中，你现在得到的将是一个非零索引，来自你的新序列。所以，起初你从零开始到某个数。但第二次时，你在索引六。但实际上你的列表开头是在索引三。所以我现在需要推算出当前的索引是多少。但无论如何，你不是都要手动做类似的事情吗？就像你说的，如果那是你答案的一部分，你就必须携带那个状态。
Well, so I mean, the, the, the, if you're not doing that kind of enumeration, you, if you're just doing some kind of like, if you build a primitive that returns you a tuple of the first max with index, you can then just apply that at every iteration where you don't need to do. the like yes you're you're definitely doing the same work every time but you're avoiding the now I need to subtract the sum of all my indices from the current index to get the correct offset but it is it is food for thought but that also the other thing is even if you had this like enumerate monad thing that's not really trivial either in an array language because you can do like a zip with index pattern but then I guess you are I think you are I probably does work. You could do a max on that two-element array. The enumeration monad is very similar to the state monad or even the environment monad, right? Because it's not really
嗯，我的意思是，如果你不做那种枚举，如果你只是做某种类似的操作，如果你构建一个原语，返回给你一个带有索引的最大值元组，那么你就可以在每次迭代时应用它，而不需要做那些事。是的，你肯定每次都在做同样的工作，但你避免了现在需要从当前索引中减去所有索引之和来获得正确偏移量的麻烦。但这确实值得深思。但另一件事是，即使你有这种枚举单子，在数组语言中也不是那么简单，因为你可以使用类似“带索引压缩”的模式，但我猜你是在做，我想你是在做，它可能确实有效。你可以对那个双元素数组求最大值。枚举单子与状态单子甚至环境单子非常相似，对吧？因为它并不是真正
writable. You're never reading it. So maybe it's just a small variation on that. Yeah. I mean, maybe there's actually a nicer way to do this where, like I'm thinking now in like Haskell brain, where it's like instead of getting the max, you just go, there's a bunch of, yeah, it's been a while since I did any, well, have I ever done any real Haskell programming? Probably not. But it's been a while since I've been working with the libraries. There was a data dot split dot list or list dot split at one point that had a bunch of like chunk before, chunk after. If there was some like split at max or split at value, you'd still need the value. So I mean, if you calculated the max and then you did a split, I don't know. I don't know.
可写的。你从来没有读取过它。所以也许它只是其中的一个小变体。是的。我的意思是，也许有一种更好的方法来做这件事，就像我现在用 Haskell 的思维在思考，比如与其获取最大值，不如直接去……是的，我已经很久没写过 Haskell 了，好吧，我真的写过真正的 Haskell 程序吗？可能没有。但我已经很久没有使用这些库了。曾经有一个 data.split.list 或 list.split，里面有一堆类似“之前分块”、“之后分块”的功能。如果有一些类似“按最大值分割”或“按值分割”的功能，你仍然需要那个值。所以我的意思是，如果你计算了最大值然后进行了分割，我不知道。我不知道。
I'm sure there are things like that. And the great thing about advert of code is that, any route to the solution is fine as long as you learn something right so it's not it's not cheating to look at someone else's solution and learn a new technique you can totally do that yeah yeah well here's a challenge to the listener if you did have been a code listener in a functional or array and you've got this kind of and that's that's why i said and ben he was like well is it elegant i threw this together but that's the thing that is very elegant it's on line 27 is that you for free with an X element. You get the index and the value in an elegant fashion.
我相信有类似的东西。Advent of Code 的伟大之处在于，任何通往解决方案的路径都可以，只要你学到了东西，对吧？所以查看别人的解决方案并学习新技术并不算作弊，你完全可以这样做。是的，是的，给听众一个挑战，如果你是一位函数式或数组编程的 Advent of Code 听众，并且你遇到了这种情况，这就是我为什么说，Ben 说“这优雅吗？我把它拼凑在一起了”，但这就是优雅之处，在第 27 行，你免费得到了一个 X 元素。你以一种优雅的方式获得了索引和值。
You get the iterator. Yeah, exactly. And it's stored all in one thing with a, you know, a de-reference operator to get the value. So it's not even like you're unbundling something into a two-touple or a pair and then using each one. It's quite elegant. It's very nice.
你得到了迭代器。没错，就是这样。它全部存储在一个东西里，带有一个解引用运算符来获取值。所以这甚至不像是在把什么东西拆解成二元组或一对值，然后再分别使用它们。这非常优雅，非常棒。
And in the instances where you need this index to do this kind of operation, this is a very, very nice way to solve it. And it's one of the things that I miss when I'm in array languages. is this. And that's why if you ever live in NumPy, they have all these variations of like ARG with Max or like they have all these like index versions of like these minimum and maximum reduction functions so that you can get the index because it is a common thing that you need to do or it's not just the maximum value. You need some index for some subsequent operation. And so they have all these duplicate operations basically, Arg Max and Argmin and all that stuff,
在需要索引来执行此类操作的情况下，这是一种非常非常好的解决方法。这也是我在使用数组语言时会怀念的东西。这就是为什么如果你经常使用 NumPy，他们会有各种变体，比如 ARG Max，或者他们有所有这些最小和最大归约函数的索引版本，这样你就可以获取索引，因为这是一种你经常需要做的操作，而不仅仅是获取最大值。你需要某个索引来进行后续操作。所以他们基本上有所有这些重复的操作，Arg Max 和 Argmin 之类的东西，
which is kind of, you know, there's some quote that says, you know, design patterns. or just addressing language deficiencies or something like that. It's, you know, like, Argmax and Argmin is one of these things for, like, an algorithmic deficiency. Like, if you, if you, uh, are, are needing to do this kind of thing, it's because we don't actually have a good, good way to do it. Anyway, so should have done it in C++ folks is the moral of this story. Well, I'm not sure that's the moral.
这有点像，你知道，有一句名言说，设计模式只是在解决语言缺陷之类的东西。你知道，像 Argmax 和 Argmin 就是这种算法缺陷的产物。如果你需要做这种事情，那是因为我们实际上没有一种好的方法来做到这一点。总之，这个故事的寓意是大家应该用 C++ 来做。好吧，我不确定这是否是寓意。
And I'm actually curious how you do this in Python, too, right? Because you don't have iterators that you can back out the, index from elegantly, right? You're probably doing some, you know, Lenn on, even if you use iterators. Actually, I don't know
我其实也很好奇你在 Python 中是怎么做到的，对吧？因为你没有那种可以优雅地提取索引的迭代器，对吧？即使你使用迭代器，你可能也在做一些 len 之类的操作。其实我不知道。
familiar. Can you get just the index from an iterator if you're in iterator land? I don't actually know the answer to that question in Python. I've never written Python code that did that.
熟悉吗？如果你在迭代器的世界里，你能只从迭代器中获取索引吗？我其实不知道 Python 中这个问题的答案。我从来没写过那样做的 Python 代码。
I don't know. Well, that was day two, day three of Avent of Code. Any other highlights that you want to mention? I mean, like I said, I haven't done anything from day three onwards but were there any favorite problems or and also too have you have you been chatting with michael about his Haskell experience because that was where this all the segue uh i have i have
我不知道。好吧，那是 Advent of Code 的第二天、第三天。还有什么你想提到的亮点吗？我的意思是，就像我说的，我从第三天开始就没做过任何事情，但有没有什么喜欢的题目？还有，你有没有和 Michael 聊过他的 Haskell 体验？因为这就是所有转折的来源，我有，我有。
you know for many of us advent of code starts out with the best of intentions and we make it through two or three days as you've experienced so i don't think michael has made it a lot further than you have but but yes uh he and i you know in the first you know in the first few days we talked about our different solutions we talked about how we'd solve solved it in Haskell. And I have to say that for a beginner in Haskell, his Haskell code is pretty nice, you know. It's a function composition and declarative style, of course. Of course, Michael is well versed in that kind of thing. But Haskell is new to him. But he seems to have taken to it very well. Interesting. Maybe we'll have to have Michael on and we can chat about his however
你知道，对于我们许多人来说，Advent of Code 开始时都怀着最好的意图，我们像你经历的那样坚持了两三天，所以我认为 Michael 并没有比你走得更远。但是是的，他和我在最初的几天里讨论了我们不同的解决方案，讨论了我们是如何用 Haskell 解决它的。我必须说，对于 Haskell 初学者来说，他的 Haskell 代码相当不错，你知道，当然是函数组合和声明式风格。当然，Michael 对这类事情很精通。但 Haskell 对他来说是新的。但他似乎掌握得很好。有趣。也许我们得请 Michael 来聊聊他的 Haskell 体验。
of many days of Aventive code, a Haskell experience. Because Haskell, I mean, people forget, but it used to be my favorite language before I discovered APL and friends. It was a short-lived favorite language period, but... You should try day six. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions.
关于 Advent of Code 的那几天，他的 Haskell 体验。因为 Haskell，我的意思是，人们忘记了，但在我发现 APL 及其同类语言之前，它曾经是我最喜欢的语言。那是一段短暂的最爱语言时期，但是……你应该试试第六天。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. Yeah. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。我是反大括号派。是的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。